we've done this a handful of times now
so I'm going to do this one a little bit
quicker and you can do the same thing
once you start to get a little more
confident ok I'm going to skip this
formula this formula I'd probably over
in tens of thousands of times ok and
once you've written it mean times will
start to get into your head it's a nice
easy symmetrical beautiful formula to
memorize it shouldn't take too long once
you start using it I'm going to go
straight to the line which has all my
actual angles in it I was L and M
opposite side is Shannon then I match it
up with the other angle side pair ok so
I'm getting signed 130 on 15 ok that's
all that's left right next one I'm just
going to go straight to what side LM is
as decimal ok so let's just simply run
that through seven she begin about point
three five seven something like that ok
so now i'm going to leave straight to
you what ln m should be by hitting
shifts over ok and I'm going to do the
approximation in one step ok so I'm
getting 21 degrees and I get into very
day 21 yeah cool ok but but I know that
there's this ambiguity here so not only
do I expect a first quadrant angle I
expect a second coordinate or another
way of saying that I expect an acute
angle and an obtuse one right that's
really just shooting for is the same
same thing so what's the obtuse version
of this guy right like a 180 take away
that which is a hundred and fifty 959
you're happy with that fine add those
two I'll get one a suit you pause for a
second you look at it you think does
this make sense what certainly looks
like one of the angles would work and
the other one looks a bit questionable
right for instance if i put 21 in here
it looks like 21 ok so
but we've already seen then just because
something looks like that you can't just
assume right so could 159 degrees work
159 degrees now we run into a problem
right we run into a bigger problem not
just the fact that i'd need to draw your
diagram but actually I can't possibly
draw a diagram okay what's my problem
yeah these two guys they can't live
together in the same triangle right cuz
100th day plus 159 is 289 whatever that
thing is it's not triangle right so
therefore this angle actually I lack
even though I got it as a result i can
actually exclude it and say it's not
going to work so i'm going to buy it
like this but angle l and m plus this
anger that i already know l and then
that's equal to 280 89 degrees right and
I always like as much as I can't
actually explain what's going on right
so that is bigger and 180 degrees but
that's impossible because I meant to be
in a triangle okay this is impossible
I'm just going to put this bit on the
side not because you have to write it
but just for your benefit in a week or
two or however long it takes for this
example to go out of your mind because
you'll read oh this is impossible but
why the reason why is because it should
only add up to a maximum of 180 actually
should be less because I've only got to
the angles I sort of third angle to
include been right so what's that
conclusion right we can use the same
rule you can get angles out but
sometimes you don't know what angle it
might be you might get an angle or its
supplement it's ambiguous okay but
depending on the question you get in
this question you could get both but in
this question you can't and you can test
it pretty quickly like you do your
common sense check you look at that and
you think could it work or does it give
you something which is plainly quickly
through okay does anyone have any
questions on that process is that makes
it just one more thing if you've got
another color please please please put a
box around this it's an important part
of your reasoning here this is me
dealing with the ambiguous case right
you can't just pretend it's not there
just by saying oh I think 21 should be
fine and I just don't like the other
angle okay you have to show why it
actually doesn't make sense it's not
hard it's not hard you need to just look
carefully at the diagram and see what it